anyway the most stressful thing ever
okay most stressful thing ever
okay yep okay you ready i think i'm
ready
okay put your pants on because this is a
this is brutal this is gonna make
you and people have probably hurt seen
this but it's gonna make all of us feel
uh is going to make all of us sweat yeah
stefan thomas a german-born programmer
living in san francisco
has two guesses left to figure out a
password that is worth as of this week
about 220 million dollars the password
will let him unlock a small hard drive
known as an iron key which contains the
private keys
to a digital wallet that holds 7002
bitcoin
while the price of bitcoin dropped
sharply on monday it is still out more
than 50
from just a month ago when it passed its
previous all-time high
of around 20 000 the problem is that mr
thomas years ago
lost the paper where he wrote down the
password for his iron key
which gives users 10 guesses before it
seizes up and encrypts its contents
forever
[Music]
oh man
are you frozen you looked very committed
to the bit there
which what bit when when the power went
out on your [ __ ]
you said this is the most stressful
thing you read it
and then your face was just like
no that's not a good it was more like
this
i think i think that it was so stressful
that my whole system was like [ __ ] this
yeah it was so stressful that your yeah
the grid
shut down literally around your place so
guys the power just went out of my place
randomly
and in the middle of that and so uh
basically took half an hour to get my
whole system up and running again
because i couldn't figure out nothing
[ __ ] works pcs suck ass
[ __ ] you you know i'm just sick of
everything you know
but you really burned a half an hour it
was like 20 minutes
yeah like and now we're gonna be late
for the [ __ ] it's just
it sucks you know i hate i have stresses
me out so much
in the middle of reading the most
stressful story of all time yeah so
my my video file on my side probably
corrupted so we're probably gonna have
to use a zoom and my zoom face is all
like
the aspect ratio is [ __ ] up though
nothing good you know there's nothing
good ever you know mozzarella
what'd you say my zoom face i like that
phrase
this is my zoom face this is my zoom
face
that's going to be the modern oh face
it's going to be the modern version of
office space
yeah we're back we're back we're back
we're back let's let's talk about the um
two guesses two guesses left out of ten
out of [ __ ] ten and the worst part is
if he doesn't get it
it like encrypts itself and he'll never
like just lost 200 million dollars just
lost
like dude that makes me sweat i would
i would like what would you do i would
kill myself
like [ __ ] 200 million dollars
and you got to live with that for the
rest of your life that you could
never that you almost had it if you just
weren't such a [ __ ] idiot and
lost that piece of paper i just wouldn't
even try
i would just perpetually say yeah i got
200 million stored away i got two
guesses left
so you'd never actually guess it no
because then you still kind of feel like
you have it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
then what if you think what if you think
oh [ __ ] i definitely know it
what if you don't you don't think so
no you don't you don't know what if one
morning like you have some crazy dream
or maybe maybe you take some dmt
and you rock it off to another world and
you see the password like engraved in
mars
and you're like that's it i'm 100 sure
that that is the password and you go
and you do it and it locks you up and it
erases everything
like there's gonna be a moment in life
where you probably think that you
definitely know what it is
so i'm saying you just leave it at the
two guesses left
yeah but if you get it then you you're a
[ __ ] bajillionaire
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want no
unless i find that piece of paper
never trying
yeah you can't i don't think i could
ever live with that because then you're
gonna have to convince yourself yeah but
life isn't about money it's about
oh yeah you've got to find a fulfilling
family and
yeah you got to become all spiritual and
[ __ ] yeah exactly yeah
it's no i find uh i finally have peace
and tell me yes i meditate now
yeah oh yeah do you meditate to get away
from the fact you [ __ ] blew
200 million dollars
[Music]
because that's what it sounds like to me
pal yeah you know
generations of your family would have
been fine
after this if you hadn't [ __ ] it up
you'd be a hero you know it's crazy
about 200 million
it's still 100 million after capital
gains tax
it's still enough money to buy your old
high school and rename it to
your name and then nutsack at the end of
it yeah and then fire the one teacher
that didn't believe in you
mm-hmm that said you were going to be
nothing
but now you are nothing you're nothing
and they were right
you still probably have 99 million left
you know what i mean
[ __ ] man you're talking about some real
sick [ __ ] here now
now i understand why you want to become
a billionaire
you know me no i understand no not no
not
maybe you do i just mean the general
desire to become a billionaire because
you know i've never
really had that desire to be like oh
yeah i want a billion dollars
yeah do you think do you think
billionaires are made or do you think
they come out the womb like
i want a billion [ __ ] dollars as soon
as they
understand what money is i i was talking
to my friend
he he makes a lot of money and uh he's a
business guy
he's what you would call a hustler he
goes to a different school but
like you wouldn't know him but like yeah
no you wouldn't know him i'll tell you
who he is afterwards
oh i think i told you about this guy
maybe he's a great guy i love him love
him to death
but i was in i was visiting and i and i
saw him
and he's like he's been through a lot of
like uh
turmoil in his businesses almost a
couple years well go ahead
maybe i think i know who this is he
looked at me in the eyes
and he said i want to be a billionaire
that's my goal and i'm not [ __ ]
around
i'm not going to be happy until i'm a
billionaire it's like damn
and he's 30 i think yeah he's my age 30.
billionaire okay billionaire of 50
though
is it even worth it i don't know i i see
i don't
the only thing that i think that could
be
uh worth it about being billionaire is
you could actually make change
in the world sure like if you want if
you wanted to do you
have the resources to actually make a
difference
yeah in terms of whatever it is like
you can hate elon musk and i and i don't
even
by the way congrats to our boy for being
the religious man shout out to our guy
shout out to our [ __ ] boy it's crazy
how
we're homies with like the richest guy
in the world
like on planet [ __ ] earth that's our
boy we have a headdress
you know i told him that the night that
we were there yeah i told him that we
were
i mean he was sipping his scotch
and uh he was like it's a school night
and i was like no but dude listen to me
man
listen to me i think that
you one day are gonna be the richest man
on earth and he was like come on come on
cody
don't flatten me like that i said no i
really think so and look at
today i mean some i i would probably say
it was because of me
yeah yeah um
yeah it's kind of funny to think about a
uh like a a
multi-millionaire sitting around
a group of billionaires feeling like a
small fry
feeling like i'll never be like you guys
you know i just run a little oil company
i'm not gonna be like you guys and then
jeff
and elon and you know whoever has to be
like no
dude no you will be a billionaire dude
just all you gotta do is hustle just
believe in yourself dogs
[ __ ] what the haters say never speak
they hate you because they
ain't you dude never stop grinding dog
by the way guys during our uh our we had
a music session yesterday and
we came up with an alternate grinder
and it's a social media app that it just
lets people know when you're grinding
yeah it's like your status is either
grinding or not grinding you can you can
check your
you know your people's grinding status
like bring up cody just started grinding
hell yeah
well you know it's me when i check in at
4 30 a.m yeah
every morning yeah because that's when i
start my grind yeah
currently grinding i'm currently
grinding right now yeah
are you yeah no definitely no hard would
you say you're grinding
um you know like a hundred
like i don't i don't it's like can't
stop won't stop for me
yeah it doesn't my dentist tells me i
grind in my sleep
yeah literally it never ends for me
seriously i mean i took my car to the
[ __ ] uh mechanic and he's like god
damn dude
you don't stop grinding i'm like nah
[Laughter]
i don't want any brake pads on my [ __ ] i
just want pure grinding
i want to feel like i'm grinding at all
times
i actually don't have tires on my
[ __ ] rims either
because i want that sensation of
grinding 24 7. just [ __ ]
completely [ __ ] up dude it's got like
probably 10 more miles before it just
falls apart
yeah yeah but i mean that's because i'm
always grinding
these guys stay grinding you know i
actually went
to like had a surgery so they removed
discs from my spine so that whenever i
squat i can feel the bones
just yeah rubbing straight up against
each other
right right i mean you should you should
like even
even in my down time like when i'm
chilling with my girl
like watching a movie or like watching
you know like the great british bake off
or whatever
where you should see us on the couch
like we're still like
spooning but like i'm going for it you
know like i'm grinding
grinding yeah like it's even like even
if we're just parallel like
like horizontal right i'm still like
yeah he's still still getting in there
the whole time just a little close on
but like we're grinding yeah
definitely because i never stopped yeah
i feel that you're gonna be a
billionaire man with that attitude
you're [ __ ] you're gonna be a
billionaire
no i was gonna say you can you can hate
elon musk and you know
he's he's definitely a controversial
person right now but like
he also is definitely contributing to
the
to uh you know the the lowering of
carbon emissions
like we wouldn't be anywhere close to
the place that we are with evs if it
wasn't for him and you could also say
the batteries probably
cause more pollution than they don't but
people are working on battery breakdown
technology
right now that's going to make that
problem go away yeah so
and that's all because and the space you
know spacex and everything it's all
because he has a [ __ ] billion dollars
he can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
yeah yeah i'm just you know
it's cool that all these guys like want
to work on the environment and stuff but
like
who's gonna you know
who's gonna who's gonna successfully
give us the limb
lengthening procedure
yeah i get yeah that's cool like [ __ ]
environment
pollution you know but who's gonna
[ __ ] make my
dick bigger dude make our dicks bigger
and make us taller and
he's gonna make a dollar how have they
not solved this yet this is like
we should have did that before cars
kind of feel like billionaires got their
priorities in the wrong place dude
so that's what we would do yeah if we
made a bill
figure out you know i want to
um apply you know
uh uh socialist
ideas to penis size
height and age i want us all to be able
to live forever
with massive dongs and be very tall
because if we all had big dicks then
none of them would be small
yep and that's what i'm looking for even
if we all had medium dicks yeah you know
it makes the other ones shorter i don't
know even them all out i know you've
seen that tick tock
which one it's like some girls like
i like i see what the government does
why can't we just print more money than
the kids
that's so funny and the kid just unless
big but go ahead and go ahead i'll let
you finish
if all penis big no penis big
subtle crime she said uh all i'm saying
is i haven't seen any evidence as to why
we can't just
print more money
oh god all
i'm saying is stop stop
never if you if you're starting out
something like that stop
all i'm saying is don't say it
yeah it's typically not a good thing
that comes
after all i'm saying is all on all i'm
saying is
that's that's the equivalent to i'm not
racist but
all i'm saying is
why can't the government
[Music]
brother back in the [ __ ] confidence
why can't the government just print more
money just print more money
[Laughter]
oh
you